U.S hospitals are as full as ever
despite the fact that the threat from
covid continues to ease when we look at
cases and deaths and there are a lot of
different things bringing people to
hospitals including heart failure kidney
failure pneumonia and all sorts of
different things as a Friday a CNN
article finds that 87 percent of
hospital beds in the state of
Massachusetts are in use and that a lot
of this has to do not just with the
triple threat of flu covid and RSV which
continues to ease but actually with
non-respiratory illness all sorts of
different conditions part of this may be
related to people who for a period of
time were actually hesitant to go and uh
seek primary care for symptoms which may
develop into emergent problems